Venezuela is undergoing some of its
worst moments this disaster is so huge
that what was once one of the largest
and most powerful oil companies in the
world paid a visa is now practically
bankrupt and has more problems including
extracting the oil so how does the oil
company with the largest reserves in the
world have problems extracting it well
that's why you need to talk about in
today's video
[Applause]
[Music]
folks I think we all probably know it
Venezuela is undergoing a true
catastrophe and not only an economic one
it is above all a humanitarian
catastrophe it's such a huge disaster
that in recent years it is caused
between three and four million
Venezuelans to flee the country that's
more than one in every 10 inhabitants
and the truth is we're not really
surprised by this see according to the
latest statistics 87% of the population
there's nearly 9 out of every 10
Venezuelans a poor and on top of that
most of NS wheras population 60% isn't
only poor they live in extreme poverty
but not only that Venezuela is burning
down according to data from the
Venezuelan social conflict observatory
in 2017 almost 10,000 protests were
registered throughout the country more
than 27 per day and what's even worse
than this
[Music]
well according to information from
Attorney General Luis Ortega since 2015
the police the National Guard the army
and the different intelligence services
have killed more than 8,000 people of
course most of them were opposes to the
regime
crisis hunger violence repression
everything indicates that Venezuela will
soon undergo a refugee crisis of
colossal dimensions because let's be
clear dear viewer let's be honest things
they're not looking good you see for
years the Bolivarian revolution of savez
Maduro and company had a great ally and
they were not talking about Cuba or
Russia or any other country as a matter
of fact we're talking about oil the
black gold that financed the revolution
for a long time the huge income this raw
material brought financed all of the
regime's
policies and they didn't really care
about the consequences sorry I mean
factories were closing foreign
investment was fleeing the country but
it didn't matter because well they have
loads and loads of money from all of
that oil but all of that well it's about
to end yeah Venezuela does have a lot of
oil but one thing is having oil and
another thing is being able to exploit
said oil did you know that paid a visa
the National Oil Company is practically
about to collapse well listen up
[Music]
the fall of Padova petroleum of
Venezuela pay de vaisseau was created by
government decree in 1976 to integrate
all the oil assets that the state had
nationalized this company soon became a
world-class Colossus
[Music]
[Applause]
but you know why well among other things
because this company has the largest
reserves on the planet and when we say
large we mean large there are more than
300 billion barrels of oil certified
here more than the reserves of Saudi
Arabia the Emirates Russia or any other
oil power now yes it is true we have
said it on this channel before
Venezuelan oil doesn't have the highest
quality but that doesn't really matter
we're talking about a huge amount of
resources almost 20% of the world's
known reserves and the fact is that this
company paid a visa peaked in production
in 1998 a year before Hugo Chavez came
to power at which time the company was
extracting three and a half million
barrels per day since then things have
changed a lot by the year of Hugo
Chavez's death in 2013 production had
decreased by 1 million barrels per day
so could it be that Hugo Chavez's
Bolivarian government didn't like oil
could it all be part of a twisted plan
do you diversify the Venezuelan economy
well no in fact it's quite the opposite
if he had a cape estar de todo nunca
nosotros shamily Manderly out today me
yo me medio de varela diario de petróleo
a whom negocio el comercio
[Music]
Hugo Chavez wanted to increase
production to 5 million barrels the
problem was that they simply weren't
able to do it but if you think that that
Commander's results were bad you haven't
seen anything yes because since Nicolas
Maduro came to power production has sunk
to 1.8 million barrels that means like
while countries like the United States
have doubles their production Venezuela
produces half as much oil as when the
Revolution began so hardly a fantastic
success
[Applause]
and if you think that that's the worst
of it get prepared to think again
because the future is looking a lot more
bleak so at this point in the video you
might be wondering well what on earth is
going on with pate of a sir
the keys of a disaster for tall head of
aces history Divya has been the story of
a disaster foretold the best example of
that is the para Juana refining complex
which consists of three crude oil
refineries and is one of the three
largest complexes of its kind in the
entire world for years it was
Venezuela's industrial pride the crown
jewel if you will however today it
barely operates at 15% capacity and all
kinds of accidents tend to happen well
why is this there's no maintenance they
sucked everything they could from
pedobear Saar without investing there's
nothing left to squeeze Pablo just pedis
plant operator and this is certainly not
an extraordinary case
at the end of October or so in the para
Juana refining complex the my refinery
spilled over two hundred thousand
gallons of gasoline into the bay a few
days later another refinery in the
complex the card on refinery --ts
offered a fire that firemen could barely
contain because they didn't even have
the foam to fight the flames
and on and on and on it goes because the
truth is that most of the oil companies
facilities are in terrible condition so
how do you think that they reached this
point again the bad video bus apostle
vamos transit van de El Camino you see
the Chavez government always saw paid a
visa as a kind of dairy cow from which
they could get all the resources they
needed for the revolution the problem is
that the oil industry requires lots and
lots of investments and these are
investments that the Venezuelan
government simply did not want to make
even with that fact it still indebted
the company to the brim and by the way
do you know how in debt of this company
is today well listen to this we're not
talking about 1 or 5 billion we're
talking about 90 billion American
dollars a fortune so big that Venezuela
could have even bought multinationals
like Goldman Sachs Nike or Siemens
[Music]
that is just an insane amount of debt do
you think that's all that's going on
well not even close they also used the
company to plug in place and hire
thousands and thousands of supporters
friends and family members from which
paid Ave sur lost even more resources
and if that wasn't enough the Chavez
regime also placed unskilled and
inexperienced personnel in management
positions while dismissing and driving
away thousands and thousands of
experienced employees because of their
political beliefs yes this is how paid a
visa ran out of money
and ran out of human resources and now
with all of this information we can
really understand why oil production is
dropping in Venezuela and of course the
consequences of all of this well that's
terrible for the country
[Music]
the consequences oil is essential for
the Venezuelan economy especially
because there's no other industry left
standing
their dependence on oil is so great that
it generates 95 percent of all foreign
currency profits in dollars and these
currencies dear viewer - escuela needs
to be able to import food medicine
gasoline yes indeed mirela still today
has to import gasoline as well as pretty
much everything else but of course
there's oil production keeps plummeting
the country is able to import less
things
and you know what since Venezuela is
producing nothing and has to import
everything the dwindling oil money is no
longer enough to pay all the bills but
of course as you all know when you spend
more money than you make money goes away
and that's precisely what's happening to
Venezuela which according to some
calculations nearly has ten billion
dollars in foreign reserves which is
their lowest number in 40 years this
means that when the money is gone
they won't be able to import anything
else than what they can buy with the
money they make from the oil which is
decreasing so you're probably beginning
to see the problem now we previously
talked about on visual politic how
Nicolas Maduro is government has tried
to buy time by resorting to
international markets to issue debt at
pretty scandalous rates sometimes as
high as 40 percent obviously issuing
debt with implicit rates of 40 percent
can only mean future ruin and in any
case that's actually no longer a
possibility in fact both the Venezuelan
government's and para visa are incurring
defaults that is they are not paying
their debts said Pete downgrades
7 sovereign Venezuelan bonds to the
default level another route they
attempted was that of the Chinese rescue
and the Chinese answered and placed more
than 23 billion dollars in loans on the
table but everything has a limit and
they are no longer willing to continue
giving more money and getting nothing in
return let me just check this out
the Chinese oil companies seen OPEC sues
peda VESA for unpaid debts the situation
dear viewer is so desperate that the
Cuban government has decided to seize
the 49% that paid a visa held in a Cuban
refinery as compensation for that unpaid
debts yep yeah they're right not even
Cuba trusts the ax murderer a regime and
it was all of this that led to the
latest chavista events for petrol
[Music]
the venezuelan cryptocurrency as we've
seen with every day that passes the
Venezuelan government has less access to
foreign currency which is obviously a
huge problem because without foreign
currency they can't import but based on
this problem an idea came up
cryptocurrency is in fashion so why not
launch their own cryptocurrency well
they did and they called it the petro
Latveria film the last good for Madeira
in petrol jmontano of total poopin Paulo
is early pizza petrol later 32 car if
you eat from to oaxaca print out one of
the kids on the order of the amount it
tells you because there are another
integral of course the petrol is a very
particular currency among other things
because it's controlled by murderous
government under these conditions that
me ask you a question would you be
willing to invest a single euro or a
single dollar into this new
cryptocurrency in other words would you
put your money in the hands of the
Venezuelan government's well you can bet
that I wouldn't not even a single penny
and precisely because no one in their
right mind would do such a thing the
Venezuelan government has had to back
this particular cryptocurrency with oil
that is each petrol will be guaranteed
by a barrel of oil from the Venezuelan
oil reserves reserves that of course are
still underground in this way the Petros
value is apparently linked to the value
of this raw material
we filled up the menu felice de la
Frontera Superman Nopalito
Depot that was open does that sound any
better well hold on familiar because we
cannot forget a detail a very very
important detail the oil reserves are of
course under the control of the
government and I wonder do you really
think that this government is going to
exploit those reserves and even if they
did do you think that really back for
petrol and what about the support rate
wouldn't the resources generated simply
be spends wouldnt they impose
restrictions or regulations that would
benefit them above all why take the risk
of investing in Petros and by the way
another important point here that petrol
it's not convertible that is to say even
though it is supposedly backed by oil
barrels you can never exchange it for
the barrel or any title that proves a
right over those barrels the petrol is a
cryptocurrency that isn't crypto that is
backed by reserves that aren't reserves
this can only be monetized with a
production that is collapsing and issued
by a government that is in default and
has no dollars Francisco Amon Aldi
professor at the race University's Baker
Institute in Houston folks the bed rate
doesn't seem to be anything more than a
last-ditch attempts to gain time and try
to obtain the greatest possible number
of dollars by taking advantage of the
popularity of cryptocurrencies and
perhaps of capital laundering because
well who would put their dollars on the
table
[Music]
the fact is that if this crypto doesn't
work and that does look like the most
plausible scenario medoras regime will
only have three options first accept
some kind of internal revolt and leave
power one way or another which seems
very difficult second use an even
tougher hand and condemn Venezuela to
even greater humanitarian disaster or
third try to get the Chinese and
Russians to buy the country's national
resources on mass and by all means such
as their refineries their oil and maybe
other raw materials that is to say they
would essentially become a sort of
colony by selling at a loss each and
every one of their crown jewels so that
the regime's elite can continue to enjoy
their standard of living so now today
Nicolas Maduro and company they're still
in power and it hardly seems likely that
Venezuela is going to have a better
future but now it's your turn would you
be willing to exchange your money for
Petros well leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos just like this
every Monday and every Thursday also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching Jane Doe podría pasar Paso
vamos transit Ando El Camino
[Music]